i think we we need to push for radical
breakthroughs
um and if you don't push for radical
breakthroughs
you're not going to get radical outcomes
it's kind of
crazy to spend your life painting if
you're painting a subject you don't want
to look at
i've gotten to paint my own painting in
business i started amazon in 1994.
when i went to seek investors the first
question i had to answer
is what is the internet want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from
the top enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one push for radical breakthroughs with
elon musk
i think we we need to push for radical
breakthroughs
um and if you don't push for radical
breakthroughs
you're not going to get radical outcomes
um
and that that does mean taking risks um
and yeah common sense that the the
if you take a big risk in order to have
a big reward there must be a big risk
it's most the time you cannot find
a big reward for small risk that's why
those are rare
so you're going to have some
proportionality the risk can reward rule
number two
construct a business that fits you with
warren buffett
i have constructed a business that fits
me
it's kind of crazy to spend your life
painting if you're painting a subject
you don't want to look at
i've gotten to paint my own painting in
business on an unlimited canvas in a way
[Music]
it's a different sort of place
i work with great group of people that
make my life very easy
and take good care of me
we have 25 people in the office and
if you go back it's the exact same 25
the exact same ones
we don't have any committees at
berkshire we don't have a public
relations department we don't investor
relations we don't have a general
counsel
we don't have a human relations
department we just don't go for anything
that
people do just as a matter of form
it's exactly the life i like and
it's not work to me it's just a form of
play basically
rule number three turn your wounds into
wisdom with oprah winfrey turn your
wounds
into wisdom you will be wounded many
times in your life
you'll make mistakes some people will
call them failures
but i have learned that failure is
really god's way of saying
excuse me you're moving in the wrong
direction
it's just an experience
just an experience just an experience
i remember being taken off the air in
baltimore
being told that i was no longer be being
fit for television
and that i could not anchor the news
because i used to go out on the stories
and my own truth was even though i'm not
a weeper
i would cry for the people in the
stories and uh
which really wasn't very effective as a
news reporter to be covering a fire
and uh crying because the people lost
their house
and it wasn't until they i was demoted
as a on-air anchor woman and
thrown into the talk show arena to get
rid of me
that i allowed my own truth to come
through and the first day i was on the
air
doing my first talk show back in 1978 it
felt like breathing
which is what your true passion should
feel like it should be so
natural to you and so i took what had
been a mistake
what had been perceived as a failure
with my career
as an anchor woman in the news business
and turned it into a talk show career
that's
done okay for me also if you want to
have unstoppable confidence and learn
from billionaires check out my 254
series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below to
figure out where your power base is
i'm here today to prove to you in two
words there's no such thing as a bad
idea and that's footless pantyhose
you really have to believe the
internet's going to be mainstream
rule number four have a dream with jeff
bezos
when i started amazon it was 25 years
ago
i started amazon in 1994
when i went to see investors the first
question i had to answer
is what is the internet none of my
investors had ever heard of the internet
and uh the
the the the idea that i had in mind was
to build
a bookstore i realized that we could
build a store
which would have every book ever printed
in any language in print or out of print
and we could do that online it would be
impossible in a physical store
and that was the founding idea of amazon
and
but did i expect what would happen today
no you know we started
uh i've been at amazon when it was one
person
me when it was 10 people when it was a
hundred people when it was a thousand
people
and today when it's you know more than
seven hundred thousand people and
approaching seventy
thousand people just here in india so
no i did not predict that and actually i
think if anybody had predicted
that they would have needed to be
immediately institutionalized in a
mental facility
because it's not a normal thing to have
happen my dream when i started amazon
was that one day we might be able to
afford a forklift
so it's been a very uh
fun journey for me and by the way i
still tap dance into work i'm having so
much fun
rule number five find your obsession
with bill gates
computers when i was young were super
expensive
and my friend paul allen and i actually
snuck into places at the university of
washington where they had computers that
weren't being used at night
and so we were fascinated by what the
computer could do
but very few people were getting
exposure we had to go
out of our way and we were lucky that we
did it all
and so then when the idea of moving the
computer onto a chip
that intel would make and that would
make the computer
literally millions of times cheaper than
the ones we were using so both more
powerful and available to people on a
personal level
then the idea of okay it would be very
different the software you needed the
way the industry would work
we were super lucky to
be there when that was happening so what
did your family think
did they say there's something wrong
with this young man he wants to just do
computers
they knew i was obsessed with computers
that i would
skip athletics that i'd go in overnight
that i'd
you know leave the house sometimes when
they prefer i went go
work at night on these things and so it
was kind of considered a little strange
and the big moment was when i said
instead of going to
part of my senior year that i wanted to
go work
for company writing software so they
were great about
allowing that to be my hobby rule number
six embrace the changes with jack ma
in this changeable world keep changing
is the best way to keep it step could be
successful
there's no there's i remember year 2000
when i tried to raise my money i went to
a lot of uh
venture capitalists they say jack give
me the business plan
i said don't have a business plan
write something and look at the others
they have such a thick business plan you
i spent a whole week right on one piece
of paper
and they said this is a business plan a
book
the book is about how to be successful
in you know doing their business in
e-commerce international i say
how can they write a book china was not
even connected to the internet
we never change our dreams but we change
ourself
we learn from the mistakes from the
others and ourselves and change and
become
successful and rule number seven the
last one before very special bonus rule
is do what you love with mark cuban
i get that question all the time so what
industry should i look at i can tell i
can tell you all about artificial
intelligence computer vision
personalized medicine
but then what right and so and maybe
you're an expert in one of those fields
and you can go for it
but what i tend to try to tell people in
terms of what does it take to be
successful
find something you love to do and then
be great at it
not average not marginal not good enough
but if you can be great at it be great
at it if you are the
greatest videographer in the history of
videographers
people don't care about cell phones what
is it
that you can do that makes them know
that what you the way you do it is
special
and if you can do that and convey it
then you'll be fine
if you're not sure then you know
you've got it you've got to decide
whether you want to stay on your own get
it
you know be a contractor or go work for
somebody
you know it just depends you know and
let me have one other thing
i i crushed myself um
and like my brothers didn't they they
took a completely different path
and they were looking just nine to five
at yada yada
not everybody's got to be an
entrepreneur and so if you if you've got
it in your blood and that's what you
want to do
then find a way to be great and if not
you know you'll figure it out you'll
find something else
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
gonna take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through
so in the comments below write down your
single biggest takeaway as well as your
specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
what is it about selling the that you
actually enjoyed that
you think most people most people don't
enjoy selling so what is it about
selling that you actually
well okay this is the first thing i'm
going to say if you don't like
selling you should really take the time
for yourself
to practice it and learn it because all
of life is sales
i mean whether you're an accountant
whether you're a stay-at-home mother and
you're trying to sell your kids on why
they need to go to bed at a certain time
or they need to do something that you
need them to do
in an interview you have to sell
yourself i mean and so
um i think it's really important to be
able to to do that
and and hardcore door-to-door sales was
incredible groundwork
and laid that laid the foundation for me
to be able to do spanx
because when i started spanx the first
two years that i was cold calling all
the
manufacturers in north carolina i only
heard one word
no yeah i mean no no no
and because i had training and just knew
i'm gonna keep going till i get that yes
that's the reason
that i was able to get through that
stage
[Music]
if you want to change your life in 30
days for free check the link right below
me
and if you want to know the seven habits
successful people have
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
i'll see you soon